alan robinson and and i i caught wind of
this last night because alan robinson
the receiver who was franchise tag 17.9
million dollar
franchise tender was adamant not signing
it not signing it there was a report
yesterday just because chris godwin
signed it allen robinson's not signing
somebody from espn checking the box got
hey i got a scoop chris goblin signed
alan robinson's not signing there boss i
got my scoop for the day
oh wait alan robinson signed you know
why i signed cause they brought in kenny
galladay
on wednesday night alan robinson signs
because he knows
that hey look around he did
you if they would remove the franchise
tender miles you think anybody's given
alan robinson
a one-year deal for 17.9 million hell no
he's not going to get that he's not
going to get anything close to that he's
not going to get an annual
average close to that so he does the
smart thing he does the only thing he
reverses course
signs the franchise tender last night at
a time when the bears
may very well have been thinking about
rescinding it
and in hindsight shame on them number
one for using it
and shame on them for not rescinding it
once they realized how depressed the
receiver market is this year
well i i think you're right about that i
mean why not just sign kenny gallaudet
at that point and and you know what you
can give him
a significantly less money probably than
you would give you're going to give now
to allen robinson and then you still
have a pretty good wide receiver now
i think robinson is better than
gallaudet so
i think that there's at least a chance
that he would get a little bit more
money
than it appears that kenny gallaudet is
going to end up receiving out there on
the open market but at the same time
yeah i think
he did the smart thing in allen robinson
by saying all right
if that's the way you're going to play
it then this is the way i'm going to
play it and i'm going to lock in this
money right now because
i'm not going to be out here you know
not making the amount of money that i
thought i was gonna make a couple of
days ago just because
there's nobody really in this wide
receiver
market right now that actually is paying
top dollar for receivers
and part of that is just the loaded
class
that is coming in these in this draft
for wide receivers and it just seems
like it's been that way the last couple
of years
and i don't know maybe wide receivers
are starting to go the way of running
backs where it's almost like
we can get a lower she a lower cost
option that might give us the same
amount of production
as we're going to get from this guy
who's already been in the league and
that could be really interesting for
wide receivers coming up down the road
um i i i'll give you a chance to guess
and this is this is non-binding there's
no stakes here no no this isn't this
isn't like no country for old men
call it heads or tails uh guess what
kenny gallaudet is looking for in annual
value
uh you said it i think at some point and
i don't remember what it is but i
wasn't it was something like 16 million
like 15.8 million
18 and a half that was a test as to
whether or not i read my text messages
18 and a half you were texting that last
night
see that's why i knew you said it i got
the numbers right i just got them in the
wrong order
uh okay yeah you you said saying
i saying that i i know you said it and
then getting it wrong does not make it
better
so i don't know pop quiz last night mike
you you you're you're the old man at the
store
when anton sugar comes in and tells him
to call it
although he called heads you called
tails and
uh then you know that's what happens you
get your chance
all right uh i'm just look folks what we
do is we send text messages to each
other
saying i'm getting this story i'm
getting this and at one point last night
i said i'm going to post the gallaudet
wants 18.5 million a year it wasn't
intended to be a quiz i just was curious
whether or not he remembered
or paid attention whatsoever or cares
whatsoever about the content that's
being put on the website
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports